[Music]
this is a satellite photo of an
uncharted island in the South Pacific
a place where myth and science meet Kong
is being reconsidered spectacle
you got Kong that's a hundred feet tall
it really has to be seen in IMAX the
whole movie just gets taken to the next
level wash in IMAX
you really just lose yourself what the
hell is this place
it tells this incredible story of man
versus nature you came here looking for
a tract n who or what am i tracking
I've been looking for this island for
years get us home with proof monsters
exist the island isn't just a place that
looks specifically like one thing as you
continue to travel through it you see
the variations it's never been touched
you don't know what to expect like any
natural jungle there are predators
you don't go into someone's house and
start dropping bombs unless you're
picking a fight
Kong is killing his men so it becomes
his mission it's time to show that man
is king he's not an animal he's not a
beast he's a being and it's just
something that we don't understand yet
he is truly monstrous in size and scale
and scope when people step foot on this
island
the first visceral response is to look
at that thing and say that's a god
that's the big one
I hope the film inspires Wonder and awe
Kong Skull Island takes you to a
different world where things are
beautiful and terrifying all at the same
time it's IMAX and it's 3d it's huge
and we're talking about one of the
greatest myths of all time
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here ha ha you
see become here experience it in IMAX 3d
these are photos of an island in the
South Pacific
the place where myth and science me we
use explosives to shake the earth
helping us to map the surface of the
island you're dropping bombs scientific
instruments then I'm monkey
like Efes n' you knew that thing was out
here I'm sorry for your man colonel but
if you want to make the sacrifice
worthwhile get us home with proof
monsters exist your friend there can put
that down what the hell is this place
that's Cohn he's King around here
Khan was pretty good kid keeps himself
mostly well you don't go into someone's
house and start dropping bombs unless
you're picking a fight we Cohen's God on
the island but the Devils live below us
and what are they called I call them
skull crawlers why never said that name
out loud before it sounds stupid now
that I say just you call them whatever
you want
[Music]
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here he should be
coming here Jin Lee ha GDG she what the
hell is